right now everybody's worried about
getting a job of some sort and making
sure they have their own but imagine
having your dream job and you know
getting paid to do what you actually
love doing which is kind of what we
sometimes think we get to do we get paid
for doing what we love to do but it's
not something that everybody in the
workforce gets now you have this big
recession and people are trying to
figure out reevaluating like what they
do how to make money doing what you like
gary vaynerchuk's
glasses his glass is half-full he grew
his love from wine into a booming
business he's the host of Wine Library
TV calm and the author of the
forthcoming book crush it turn your
passion into profit in a digital way and
by the way you got a book deal for seven
for ten books with Harper Studio tell us
tell us what we're talking about here
how does a guy you have 145 how many
people follow you on twitter 350,000 oh
my god you are phenomenal you are by
definition a phenomenon what what
exactly is going on here why are people
following you what are you telling them
I care and see what people need to
understand is the way we communicate
today is so different yeah and the
platforms have been redefined you know I
was a wine shop owner in New Jersey had
a passion about wine
took a camera started putting it out
there and just put it out there and just
hustled worked every day answered every
email and so we were winding questions
questions about what absolutely first
two years I didn't really play my
business card until like late oh seven
about how I did it everybody just
thought I was crazy and ate dirt with
Conan O'Brien and that's how it happened
but at the end of day what I realized
what I saw in late oh five was that the
world completely changed Marketing has
changed business has changed
personal brand has changed it's a
two-way conversation now Ally you know
it's not just we dictate people want to
interact and I interact a lot if you're
on the leading edge of that you're on
the leading edge talking back to people
people are getting through the
traditional forms of media because they
want to get the information that they
want you're giving it to no question
people want to you know touch and feel
their brands or celebrities their
products you know you think it's hard
explaining Twitter today I've been using
this since oh six Wow so okay well then
can you explain it yeah we're both on
Twitter as you are but we don't have
nearly quality a little bit because I
don't do it as frequently as I should if
you're doing you're having a short
conversation it's like the running
thoughts in your head to the
we want to hear what you have to say
people have a billion different things
here's what it really is it's
word-of-mouth on steroids it's the fact
that you could put something out there
and the people that care about that if
it's quality because content is always
key if it's like quality it gets
expanded in so many directions and
that's the real power of it everybody
now has a voice it's not just certain
select view alright so I want to put
this up on screen to show people and
this applies to entrepreneurs or big
businesses you're saying you said
content is Kent King create content yes
a treat Twitter as a cocktail I love
that I love that so a lot of people are
confused of how to use Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr which is a site that
a lot of people will be talking about in
a couple years you have to treat it not
as a presentation but by working the
room right when you go to a cocktail
party alley you're not always talking
about business right if you're the
gardener in town you're not pitching
everybody it may come into the
conversation but you're also talking
about the literally game the weather you
know Shaquille O'Neal whatever you're
talking about and to me that has to
translate to this these platforms
Twitter Facebook Tumblr they're just a
translation from the real world you know
somebody said to me treat it like a bit
of a give-and-take if you were in a
cocktail party and you just did all the
talking and it was just a pitch and it
was just all about you people will get a
sense of that invite others in retweet
on Twitter for instance or send out on
Facebook other interesting things that
you learned that you thought the people
who are your friends might want to know
about you know where that started wrong
somebody told me just do it just come
from here you come from the heart and
you treat it as a real product not like
how am I gonna use this everybody's
trying to figure out how to game it how
do you use it that's just a total wrong
approach use it to communicate that's
what people like game over how do you
turn it into something that is going to
make you live your dream and that's
where it shifts I believe everybody
needs a platform a home base you know my
home base lives online yours lives on
television whatever it is you may be a
written word and you might not be an
extrovert you might want to write but if
you put out quality content and use
things like Twitter and Facebook to
shake people's hand to bring them to
your content all of a sudden you have
eyeballs let's be very honest the
confusion of how Twitter or Facebook are
gonna make money is silliness if you
don't understand that eyeballs turns
into cash then you don't understand
business and if I every major business
should be
running around trying to find people
like you so that they can figure out how
to reach out I mean maybe that's a
business opportunity here's my question
how far does the conversation go this is
a very interesting conversation you're
gonna write ten bucks yeah what what how
far do you go in to crush it's so big
Don the first but another nine won't
really go bad
no but you here's what it is here's what
really is the shift
nobody can wrap their head around
traditional people yeah that have been
in business for a long time whether
personal brands or products can't wrap
their head around the fact that they
don't control the message of the brand
anymore a your fans control the message
they're the ones talking about it and
the way you respond to them is the game
not what you tell them so what does that
mean does that mean that the idea is
you're listening as much as you're
feeding out there no the idea is you're
listening all the time you listen that's
the game everybody wants to talk but
it's about listening it's about caring
and most of all you have down the chops
if I didn't know anything about wine it
wouldn't matter if I knew how to
leverage all this because when they
watched a show or two they're like that
guy's full of crap I don't know what you
know when you let what you good and
that's what gets really interesting if
you're working a nine-to-five and really
where the books going is you know those
after hours start talking about
gardening or if you love you know
hurling I don't know whatever your
passion is talk about that live in the
communities that talk about it you
search Twitter to find people talking
about it and really get in there one
thing we know is these nice nice all
this technology brings all of the niche
people together so that you find that
there might be just a few people who
like what you like there are millions of
people out there that love the Smurfs I
mean you can make seventy thousand
dollars a year talking about the Smurfs
that's the world we live in Ali that's
the world we live in my man so I mean to
me that's fascinating and exciting but
the reality is here you are talking
whether it's Murph's or its wine or it's
gardening or it's curling you're talking
about things that are hobbies that are
that may not have paid you anything in
the past but that you can now find an
interest group I'm still make the
connection for I'll make the connection
of money on this if I am talking about
cereal and I review cereal every single
day and forty five thousand people a day
start watching that because the content
is good it's silly it's interesting it
goes viral well let me promise you
something if you don't think every
cereal producer in the world is gonna
start
sending you emails I get emails now from
every glass maker from bottled I'm
getting on for thousands of dollars a
week to put a bottled water on my table
product placement
everything that's relevant in movies and
television is relevant online because if
you can get the eyeballs and the only
way can do that is to have a lot of
passion and chops for that subject
matter but even cereal somebody's going
to want to monetize how do you be the
show to end right now so I start getting
online and doing all this I know it's
incredible
wait what about for the kids who are
graduating from college right now I mean
I'm so lucky so let's so I'm lucky lucky
why because they're not gonna go to like
standard you know square jobs they're
gonna have to hustle this conversation
is starting you're putting me on this
platform a lot of people gonna see it
and they're gonna realize oh my god I
can really talk about hip hop and if I'm
good at it and if I hustle listen I
preach an exciting thing let make no
mistake about it this is a lot of work I
mean I spent seven eight nine hours a
day answering emails going into wine
communities becoming part of the
conversation but if you do that and
you've got some skills and knowledge you
absolutely have an opportunity to
monetize and a lot of kids aren't gonna
get jobs they're gonna have no
alternatives they're gonna do this they
already kind of know how to use Facebook
and Twitter and they've got an amazing
opportunity what is this what is this
vibe been like for you from going from a
wine guy in New Jersey to now kind of
you know a leading edge thinker on
content and as he said a phenomena you
know I want to buy the New York Jets so
I don't really I don't really think
about what's happening right now I think
about where I'm going and by the way
that's a big factor in all this it's not
about what's happening right now Twitter
and Facebook are tools Twitter and
Facebook are markers and crayons right
they're a fax machine it's the fact that
we're changing and the platform the
internet the internet that we know is 14
years old people are under estimating
how powerful the global platform is this
is fantastic thank you it's very
exciting and when you're when you're out
tweeting just ask a few people to join
you got it you and I are gonna have to
kick it up well wait okay I'm
embarrassed I was how to kick it up a
little more weekly okay after this
discussion we're gonna go and tweet and
what are we telling we're telling you
that yours again you're missing the
point and I'm not you okay go to
Twitter yeah and search your name's see
what people want from you and give it to
them they say Ali what's your favorite
sport soccer but you know what I mean I
was waiting there second griddling Joe
no they don't want they don't want you
to tell that they want you to internet
right we're gonna do it that's our work
for today we're gonna be answering a lot
of questions for you Gary man has
changed my life
fascinating thank you for being with
which we use the best of luck and we're
gonna follow what you're doing Gary
Vaynerchuk is the host of Wine Library
TV calm and he is it how do you get you
on Twitter
Gary baby ger are Vee don't use it takes
a lot to have that many followers on
Twitter and it also takes a lot to get a
10 book deal I mean you're saying
something that people want to hear and
so uh I have the chops I'm not scared I
mean I really know what I'm doing I'm
consulting for a lot of fortune 500
companies this is not a joke people
think it's silly people don't get it
they want to make fun of it cuz they
don't understand this game is changing
and if you're not on board you're gonna
lose yeah
all right got it thanks Gary